bei corona gibt es eigentlich jeden tag
etwas neues aber wir stellen fest dass
mit den kindern immer stärker wieder
angst gemacht wird wir haben das im
letzten jahr erlebt beim thema lockdown
auch bei der frage dürfen kinder ein
ihre großeltern beispielsweise sehen
dann sollten die schulen erst gar nicht
geschlossen werde und als erstes wieder
geöffnet während sie waren am ende
gerade die kinder und die jugendlichen
diejenigen die am längsten unter der
pandemie gelitten haben und das was
jetzt auch wieder passiert das kann man
schon als echte kinderfeindliche politik
bezeichnen es wird wieder angst gemacht
und zwar mit kindern die eingeliefert
sind in krankenhäusern bei dem man co
wird festgestellt hat gibt die virologin
männer die bringt man die genau das
sagte jetzt waren vor mehreren hundert
toten kindern im herbst wenn man sich
also nicht jetzt schnell impfen lassen
würde aber wir stellen fest und das ist
ganz ganz wichtige viele ärzte die auch
diese darstellung zurückweisen dass
viele kinder dass zum einen die zahl der
kinder auf intensivstationen seit mai er
seit mehreren monaten nahezu konstant
ist obwohl wir ja steigende kobe zahlen
auch wieder oder infektionszahlen sehen
und das zweite ganz wichtig dass viele
viele kinder die in krankenhäuser
eingeliefert sind bei denen es heißt sie
sind wegen corona in krankenhäusern gar
nicht wegen corona in den krankenhäusern
sind dollar beispielsweise wegen eines
armbruchs eines blinden durchbruchs und
bei denen man beim abstrich festgestellt
hat acht hoops die haben auch noch
profit er sagt was völlig anderes und
ich glaube dass es in der debatte ganz
wichtig dass man das immer wieder heraus
stellt warum sind kinder in
krankenhäuser eingeliefert und dann
gibt's nebenbei noch andere dinge die
bei feststellt sind auch noch löcher in
den zähnen deswegen würde man nicht
sagen ganz ganz viele kinder wegen
werden wegen löchern 10 eingeliefert
also diese angstmache diese panikmache
das ist kinder
[Musik]